das ist also in mas neuer coo die rede
ist von einem laser scheibenwischer der
fahrzeugscheiben durch den beschuss von
laserstrahlen reinigen soll
der us-autohersteller tesla hat diese
neuartige technik jetzt zum patent
angemeldet doch es gibt noch einige
herausforderungen zu bewältigen
damit diese laser scheibenwischer ist
tatsächlich in die entwicklung schaffen
klicks um science fiction die jetzt
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen teslas neues patent
heißt pauls laser cleaning auf dem
rescue me later on glass artikels in
vehicles übersetzen kann man das in etwa
mit pulslaser reinigung von schmutz
teilen die sich auf den scheiben und dem
glas von fahrzeugen absetzen
der us-autohersteller tesla hat er einen
entsprechenden patentantrag bereits im
mai 2009 10 bei den zuständigen behörden
eingereicht doch veröffentlicht wurde
die patentschrift erst jetzt laut dem
us-unternehmen tesla dessen mitbegründer
ihren maske ist soll diese technik unter
der fronthaube von fahrzeugen angebracht
werden
das neuartige laser modul müsste dem
dreck zunächst erkennen und dann
einschätzen wie verschmutzt die
glasfläche wirklich ist dementsprechend
sollen dann laserstrahlen impuls artigen
stößen ausgesendet werden die den groben
schmutz von der windschutzscheibe
entfernen die große herausforderung
dabei die ablagerungen müssen möglichst
gründlich entfernt werden doch dabei
darf der leser die windschutzscheibe
keinesfalls beschädigen die leser sollen
dabei ähnlich wie die scheibenwaschdüsen
angeordnet sein
doch die technik kann laut den bislang
veröffentlichten bilder wohl auch an den
seitlichen blinkern und an den
scheinwerfern eingesetzt werden
möglicherweise könnte damit auch die
optik verschiedener kamerasensoren
schneller gereinigt werden und das ist
ja eine wichtige bedingung für das
unterstützte und autonome fahren
denn wenn die kameras verdreckt sind
funktionieren bei fahrzeugen bestimmte
features nicht wie zum beispiel das
automatische überholen das habe ich
selbst schon erlebt stadt zu überholen
gibt es dann eine fehlermeldung
in der patentschrift wird allerdings
ausschließlich die entfernung von die
breeze behandelt und das heißt auf
deutsch so viel wie ablagerungen von
flüssigkeiten ist dagegen nicht die rede
was ist also mit regentropfen die auf
die windschutzscheibe fallen
und die sicht einschränken genau dieser
entscheidende aufgabe wird das neue
system von testa wohl nicht gerecht
jedenfalls geht aus der patentschrift
nicht hervor ob die technik die neue
technik auch regentropfen entfernen kann
so wird gerade in fachkreisen gemutmaßt
ob zusätzlich zum einsatz des neuartigen
leser des systems auch weiterhin der
gewöhnliche schreiben genutzt werden
müsste wischer und laser würden sich
dann also die arbeit teilen
das wiederum passt hervorragend mit
einem weiteren neuen technik von tesla
zusammen anfang diesen jahres 2009 10
männlich hatte der autohersteller ein
elektromagnetisches scheibenwischer
system zum patent angemeldet diese
scheibenwischer sind in der lage in
einer linearen bewegung von links nach
rechts über die komplette frontscheibe
zu fahren und diese in einem gang
komplett abzuziehen
also nicht mehr die kreisförmigen
sauberen bereiche auf der
windschutzscheibe und der rest ist nass
und dreckig
doch nach ansicht unabhängiger fachleute
gibt es bei der lasertechnik ein
entscheidendes problem denn die
laserstrahlen könnten für die autofahrer
oder autofahrerin und die weiteren
insassen zur gefahr werden
sie könnten geblendet oder sogar
verletzt werden und um gegen den groben
schmutz auf der scheibe überhaupt
anzukommen müsste der leser entsprechend
stark sein und zwar so stark dass er im
worst case sogar die augen flüssigkeit
der insassen verdampfen lassen könnte
auch technisch gesehen gibt es wohl noch
einige herausforderungen zu bewältigen
um flächen wirklich effizient reinigen
zu können müssen sie das lasersystem
nämlich eigentlich senkrecht auf die
windschutzscheibe zielen doch wie soll
das gehen wenn der leser unter der
fronthaube installiert wird und somit
schreck auf die scheibe trifft in
fachkreisen wird außerdem diskutiert wie
das neuartige lesesystem erkennen kann
welche art von schmutz zu entfernen ist
denn nur so kann die entsprechende
intensität eingestellt werden feststehen
jedenfalls lasertechnik eignet sich zur
reinigung funktioniert und wird bereits
seit einiger zeit in verschiedenen
bereichen eingesetzt beispielsweise für
die reinigung von alten gemälden und
auch die us luftwaffe muss lasersysteme
und flugzeugen zu reinigen und auch in
der autobranche selbst ist der einsatz
von lasertechnik prinzipiell nichts
neues die laser scheinwerfer von bmw und
audi beispielsweise sind allerdings für
das menschliche auge ungefährlich tesla
möchte sein neuartiges system auch in
anderen bereichen einsetzen
beispielsweise bei solaranlagen auf
hausdächern
hier könnte das lasersystem
eine maximale lichtdurchlässigkeit
sorgen und somit die leistungsfähigkeit
der panels garantieren und noch eine
tesla erfindung teslas neue super
batterie 1,6 millionen kilometer mit dem
auto anklicken anschauen und den
megacoolen kanal breaking lab abonnieren
das lohnt sich wer es nicht macht
bekommt strafpunkte also bis dann bleibt
dran